[Music]
so you see doc um sure they may have
found me in the end
but did I ever really find myself
Melissa Nemo I'm really disappointed in
you Oh No why because that joke was
god-awful a real pile of carp I thought
you were supposed to be a clownfish
all right good session today see you
next week buddy thanks for ending it on
a good joke but I wasn't joking
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
home to the most sophisticated fan
series on the internet with Pixar back
in the news for its newest film tale of
two guys living in a gritty urban world
filled with magic called bright airy
lives don't matter today no idea is
everywhere these days isn't he oh wait
no no sorry got it confused with the
other movie about two guys living in a
gritty urban world filled with magic
this one is called onward which I'm
being honest as an equally non
interesting non descriptive title as
bright so really the two movies are
practically the same thing anyway none
of it matters cuz I haven't seen it yet
not talking about it yet nope today
we're flashing back to Pixar's past with
a deep dive into the Finding Nemo
franchise to explore a plot point that
may have some significant implications
for our dad son duo as well as the
eventual third movie and the franchise
cuz we all know it's coming now
obviously animated movies with talking
animals are expected to take a few
liberties going in the audience
understands that not everything in the
movie is gonna be a hundred percent
realistic it's why most of us can watch
the circle of life seen from The Lion
King without needing there to be a zebra
getting its throat ripped out by a
hungry cheetah however there are some
people out there who just can't stand a
movie with factual inaccuracies like
that and no his name is not just Matt
Pat's or at least I mean I'm not alone
case in point the director of Finding
Nemo Andrew Stanton who's been very
vocal about his need for scientific
accuracy in the Finding Nemo movies when
he watched The Lion King it rubbed him
the wrong way
so when developing Finding Nemo Stan
very intentionally sought to present
animal king
with truth even when the truth was
unfair or brutal stam explains quote
nemo is working with the real world the
real predatory world and was definitely
a response to the Lion King I liked
working with the limitations of the
rules of nature supposed to breaking the
rules and saying everything's in it for
the circle of life end quote as a result
the Nemo films are chock-full of marine
biology facts and truths what you want
to do is follow the EAC Australian
current yep totally a real thing that
exists and that fish used to migrate
let's name the zones of the not just too
catchy song but also a nice way to
remember the different zones of the
ocean French North even this is housed
in some level of fact there are certain
species of shark that are able to
survive on a mostly vegetarian diet but
just how truthful was Andrew willing to
go because Nemo and Marlin are clownfish
and clownfish harbored themselves an
interesting anatomical secrets you see
in the absence of a female in the colony
a male clownfish will become female
that's right according to everything
scientists currently know about
clownfish if Nemo's mom had truly been
killed by a barracuda like we see in the
opening of the movie in Marlin Nemo's
dad would have immediately begun the
process of becoming a biological female
that's because clownfish are what's
known as protandrous hermaphrodites
which means that they're born with
immature reproductive organs the male
organs develop first around the age of 2
and the female organs only developed
later should the clown fishes colony
need him to step up because clownfish
colonies have themselves only one female
at a time and she only mates with the
dominant male if and when the female
dies the dominant male then steps up and
turns into the dominant female but
that's not the big reveal I'm talking
about when it comes to Finding Nemo no
there's one last twist of the story with
our dominant male in this case Marlin
now female it leaves the role of the
dominant male vacant
means that one of the immature males
from the colony has to move up into the
role of the breeding male but an emos
colony there's only one other fish to
fill that role nemo himself meaning that
when Marlin transitions into a
biological female Nemo would then
biologically be required to move up into
the role of the dominant male in other
words in a completely realistic version
of this movie Nemo would then procreate
with his own parent Marlin I know our
unofficial tagline is ruining your
childhood but seriously this one is
really gunning for that title no in all
seriousness surely Disney doesn't intend
for their animated family franchise to
be interpreted this way right I mean we
see a whole lot of Marlin after his wife
quarrel dies and everyone including
Marlin himself only ever identify him as
being male without question a year later
during the events of finding dory Marlin
is still being referred to as a he and
there's certainly no evidence that
Marlin & Nemo are you know taking a role
in the anemone in finding Dory the two
of them still live alone without any
signs of tiny clowns around sorry tiny
clowns led to a scary visual their tiny
underwater clowns are the stuff of
nightmares let me rephrase that the two
still live alone without any signs of
tiny clownfish around thank you said
Andrew Stanton I liked working with the
limitations of the rules of nature as
opposed to breaking the rules probably
regret making that comment now huh then
again Stanton very very clearly did his
research on clownfish he sought to show
the animal kingdom in a realistic light
and it appears everywhere you look coral
and Marlin embody the typical clownfish
family dynamic to a tee as the most
dominant member of their school's female
clownfish are the ones who venture out
of the anemone and defend their homes
against predators while male clownfish
tends the children and rarely stray far
from the anemone Coral in true female
clownfish fashion does not back down
from the Barracuda and dies defending
her eggs
likewise Marlin is nurturing and over
cautious about straying too far from
home clownfish are basically the only
fish in the sea that don't get stung by
an anemone and the films are sure to
toss that factoid in there too even when
we get to finding Dory the aquarium is
littered with marine biology facts so
just how far were they willing to push
the scientific factual 'ti of this movie
well
come as a surprise the very few of you
and I have myself a theory a film theory
I think they're doing it I think this is
exactly what is happening in these films
not the part about Nemo obviously that
would be aligned too far but I do think
that Marlin may in fact be changing
biologically to a female clownfish right
in front of our eyes just hear me out on
this as you might assume it's gonna take
some time for the dominant male
clownfish to fully change biologically
into a female in fact a 20-19 study
found that a dominant male clown fishes
organs can take years to fully develop
into female parts but they also found
that the change from male to female
begins first in the clown fishes brain
before any actual physical changes are
detected in their mating organs meaning
that a dominant male clown fishes
behaviors will turn female almost
immediately as soon as the death of the
female clownfish happens in the colony
so again to summarize because this is
important the behavioural changes happen
right away and that physiological
changes occur later so what does this
mean for the character of Marlin well it
means that Marlin should be exhibiting
female behaviors shortly after we see
coral die and wouldn't you know it
that's exactly what we see happening
let's create a timeline shall we
Marlins transformation begins the moment
coral is killed by the barracuda we'll
call this day 0 at that point Nemo is an
egg that's just a couple of days from
hatching after the Barracuda attack
leads Marlin with only one viable egg to
raise we leap forward in time to win
Nemo as a juvenile clownfish which would
put in between ages of nine and fifteen
months old at this stage efficient
Marlins physician should be exhibiting a
fully developed female brain and we'd
expect to see Marlin exhibiting female
clownfish characteristics and behaviors
like issuing warning calls or even
launching attacks while remaining
cautious about venturing too far from
the anemone and as the film's progress
we do in fact see Marlin becoming
assertive in brand new ways
he's been backing sharks and jellyfish
all sorts of that can't be here he's
sure what was his name that's some sort
of sport fish or something tuna good
trout that's it
Marlin the little clownfish from the
reef
[Music]
I heard he took on three
and Marlon certainly does remain
cautious about venturing too far from
the anemone even throughout the course
of finding Dory which occurs one year
later so this means at the conclusion of
finding Dory roughly two years from day
zero approximately 9 to 15 months at the
end of the first movie plus 12 months in
the second movie or about 24 months
total Nemo is now two years old and
theoretically Marlin has been undergoing
this changing process for two years does
this theory hold water based on the
timeline of events yes you see the
two-year mark just so happens to be the
pivotal point in time for both Nemo and
Marlin for Nemo he's reached the end of
his adolescence clownfish reach
reproductive maturity after the two-year
mark so Nemo is on the very cusp of this
moment when finding Dory concludes this
means that the next time we see Nemo
he's finally gonna be able to step up
into the role of the breeding male but
as we all know it takes to two
underwater tango and at the two-year
mark Marlin is still likely going
through his transformation in that 2019
study I referenced earlier researchers
observe the changing clownfish for a
three-year period with the study
concluded after those three years only
three of the seventeen males had fully
completed the gonad all changed to
females so all of this is to say when
finding Dory concludes we wouldn't
expect clownfish and Nemo and Marlins
positions to be rubbing fins but we
would expect them to start the process
in the near future so this feels like a
smart place for Disney to end its
family-friendly franchise because from
here on out things are gonna start to
get hashtag awkward so there you have it
folks this is why we're never gonna get
Finding Nemo 3 because if the director
is truly committed to scientific
accuracy in his movie then there is no
world no world where a Nemo 3 could
happen surely nothing could convince
Disney to undermine its commitment to
entertaining broad family audiences with
base level entertainment not even money
rights rights well just how much money
are we talking about here exactly
because from a financial standpoint the
Finding Nemo franchise is an absolute
cash cow the Finding Nemo duo G has made
more money than any other duology and
Pixar history in fact when adjusted for
inflation Finding Nemo and finding Dory
are pics
number one and number two
highest-grossing films ever and from a
creative standpoint director Andrew
Stanton hasn't ruled out the possibility
of a third Nimmo movie here's another
quote from him I really do feel like
this was the missing piece emotionally
for the first movie now I've stopped
saying never for anything because there
are a lot of characters that get
introduced and we've broadened the
universe for this movie again I'm very
used to seeing that world continue to
open up from the Toy Story movies so
I've learned is just saying to my
knowledge I think everything that was
born of the first movie is wrapped up
we'll see anyway but let's take a look
at that last comment shall we everything
that was born in the first movie is
wrapped up
not quite Andrew you see I'm thinking
the strongest argument for a third Nimmo
movie is from a story standpoint the
three main characters in both these
films are Nemo Dory and Marlin first
Marlin found Nemo in Finding Nemo
then Marlin found Dory and finding dory
and up next naturally we would expect
Marlin to find Marlin this won't be so
much a physical search for Marlin as it
is a story of internal discovery as
Marlin shoulders new gender roles made
his own biologically mandated role
change it's like a marine biologists
version of transparent he's discovering
himself as a new fish as the fish that
he was always born to be I mean that'll
be kind of tough to cut out for China
they're Disney but then again some
things are bigger than China Disney
could definitely use the P R after being
pummeled in recent years for its
lackluster portrayal of LGBT+ characters
let's face it a story like this is still
rooted in the real world science that
Andrew Stanton founded these movies on
in the first place but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and
[Music]